I took a trip to Armenian we've made a
show about it and while I was there I
went on to Armenian television shows
which was a fascinating experience to
see other countries versions of kind of
art types of shows you had a similar
experience you'd been on some Japanese
TV shows to promote to promote movies in
the past yeah I've heard they're insane
but I've never actually been on one
what's it like they're pretty crazy I
mean we weren't actually like in the
studio in Japan I have filmed some stuff
in Japan which is also crazy but at
Spain is also remarkably crazy to write
their late-night shows but but there was
this one girl who got brought out to the
Harry Potter set from Japan she's been
flown over to meet us and she was she
for some reason they couldn't just be
like it's a nice trip you're gonna meet
the guys and see the sets they had to be
like they had to like put us to through
some kind of emotional torment okay so
she got to the set and she's flown like
thousands of miles and there will by the
way Emma Dan and Rupert they're just not
gonna say hi to you they're not gonna be
they told this girl he's like you guys
are not going to show up I think she has
expressly traveled to meet us they won't
know they're not gonna they're not gonna
be there so she must have been crushed
so she was like a crush but then I
thought think like four well I'm still
here like I'll make the best of it even
though those guys have been inexplicably
horrible to me I'll still kind of try
have a nice day
and then and there cuz because they
wanted to like surprise her with us so
but like right I feel like he would been
happy anyway and they didn't need to
like me
relegate Hadj oh they're so crazy about
putting her through that torture of no
nope you flew thousands of miles but
Daniels not gonna be here it's not how
stuff you want to see you I'm sorry I
don't know what it is like it's so
horrible they made her absolutely
miserable and then they spring you and
they sprang me on her and I believe
Rupert as well and she was she was
fascinated but we actually have the clip
it's horf its beauty it's horrifying at
first but then there's such she does
some great things yeah take a look
Gryffindor
[Applause]
yeah she did the same thing to Rupert
grints eyelashes because he's because
he's redheaded like you she was like
fascinated by that cuz there's not
already yeah yeah we're like alien so
yeah I'm gonna go over there and do the
show and they're just doing so like
taller than the entire country
everyone's like my height so like it's
you'll just be like yeah yeah you you
people will come and talk to you I will
absolutely love that clip let's take a
quick break much more with Daniel
Radcliffe and decides agree hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos please